what's up everybody hello how's it going
good afternoon today pressure here
Richie is joining me what's up y'all
good afternoon
chin chillin right now about to play
some Call of Duty very very soon um but
you know while people join us and join
this dream we are gonna have a little
chat because there's a lot of Call of
Duty things to talk about so give us 10
minutes at a time and then we're gonna
hop into some call of duty modern
warfare season to season to baby hey
guys update this morning it slowed us
down in our tracks
exactly usually we stream at 11 a.m.
every morning but we wanted to play this
that the update was huge took forever
for us to download it and honestly I
noticed there was a bit of I don't know
technical difficulties across the board
because a mixes duo's Valentine's Day
event actually got postponed until
tomorrow it was all supposed to go live
yeah definitely a lot going on this
morning but it's all good we'll play
some apex tomorrow gonna play some call
of duty today oh yeah but yeah let's
talk Cod because yeah we have season 2
launching today we'll go over some more
of those details in details but a new
Call of Duty game is releasing this year
you guys oh yeah this year confirmed
100% confirmed and the fact that they
have started season 2 for modern warfare
shows that they're still making content
for this game there's also a very
interesting-looking classified section
on the current main menu of modern
warfare which we will show you guys
shortly um but yeah so they're still
making content for this but a new one is
being released yeah this year same
timeframe as many Call of Duty games are
to be released they're even saying
though Activision announced like their
it won't sell new it won't sell as well
as modern warfare dude they're just they
said that they exactly in there was it
like a trade me I forget what it was it
was like their official Oh what's it
called I forget you know
article included a link to that article
in the chat right now if you guys want
to give it a read while we're talking
about it but a few interesting things to
know is that it's being released
released at the end of this year
alongside obviously the next generation
so I could only assume they've been
making this for like ps4 PS I mean PS 5
the new Xbox yes it was their earnings
call that's what it was called sorry I
feel backtracking a little bit they they
announced all this stuff at their
earnings call they definitely planted a
new call of duty but yeah of course
they're going to continue content for
this it's only season 2 season 2 though
is massive yes indeed so something to
look forward to
towards the end of this year for all the
Call of Duty heads out there
I can definitely admit I've purchased
way too many Call of Duty games over the
years but that's obviously not gonna
stop because there's another one coming
out yep um so let us know in the chat
right now you guys what do you want to
see in the new Cod yeah where do you
think they'll go from here interesting
that they're already not expecting much
out of it sales wise which is something
really weird to hear from that's
something like you might say but like
it's weird to hear that from like
Activision themselves they're they're
predicting lower sales than Modern
Warfare I think because modern warfare
was such a big like return you know so
many millions of dollars went into
modern warfare and it's sold like you
know hotcakes so that's good that they
appreciate that so much but hearing that
uh this one's this next one might not do
so hot in comparison is a little weird
but you know we'll cover as soon as it
comes out any news exactly so make sure
you check that out but aside from that
and I'll still be taking a look to see
what you guys want to see in the next
Cod but let's talk about season 2 for
modern warfare a little bit because
there's a lot coming with this new
update I mean it was already 51 gigs
yeah there's more on the way there but
some classified things even a classified
weapon so let's talk about day one today
what's coming today Ritchie ooh let me
just start by saying it was like 51
games on PlayStation 68 gigs on piece
and somewhere in the middle I think 60
gigs on Xbox so it was a heavy download
this morning but there's a lot to talk
about a lot was added including two new
guns which we have for you today the new
battle pass system a few maps including
the return of rust one-one me on rust
what do you want me bro and then the
Atlas superstore which is a smaller map
which is already in the game have you
played any of the spec ops Persia one of
the young ah there's a ver dansk map
it's very big and there's kind of like a
Costco store within that map and that
little Costco store that I'm describing
is a new map it on its own so it's kind
of small it sits there a lot of things
blocking you a lot of pallets and boxes
and things like that so there's and
there's also the return of ghosts of
course from modern warfare to Fame yes
wonderful it's good to see him we
unlocked him so we will be playing as
him he's got a bunch of new skins of
course there's a bunch of sprays and
gestures and things like that stickers
and charms that have been added to
season 2 but those are little things the
biggest thing is probably the new ground
war map it's probably what took up the
most space on this download this morning
few new maps new multiplayer maps and
one new ground war map gun fight maps
have been added yeah
and they added a new play mode 3v3 gun
fight they did I noticed playing this
morning grinding a little bit but they
also have more down the line that all
that we just talked about now was day
one so later on down the season they
have another map - one more character
named Talon on day one it says only
ghost is released but there's ghosts and
mace he's available if you grind the
battle path hard enough so same with
Talon I believe those games yeah
mace looks like a buff ghost that's all
he has the same mask except he's like
yoked to the max you guys seen the
trailer but there's also gonna be a new
gun down the line it's just blurred out
like classified we're not exactly sure
what it is but and as well as new game
modes down the line a lot for day one
but more to come too for just the rest
of season two it's gonna be a big season
honestly the infected ground word moving
the season sounds that really really
scary I don't know a mad just imagine
ground war I know I'm just trying to
figure out exactly how it's gonna play
out I can't really picture it so I'm
excited to see how it's gonna be
gunfight variants like I mentioned just
a few seconds ago it's my favorite game
type so the fact that they got new maps
and some new variants on the way for
that playlist is really exciting too so
yep definitely
Bob God alright ground war already
stresses me out on its own I love the
plan and in fact it stresses me out like
10 times more than that right and I
don't know I I just freaked out I'm not
that good at it but we definitely have
to try it when it comes when ground war
what's called song I keep wanting to say
zombies infected comes out you know
we'll be here trying it out because it
just sounds like chaos but today the
biggest announcements are probably
ghosts returning to new guns and rust
which we all have unlocked because we
picked up the battle pass this morning I
grind it a little bit because of our
delayed this morning big download it
didn't work out first thing in the
morning but we're here something else
worth noting that is being released with
day one right now go play right now for
you competitive heads out there we've
got the gun fight tournaments and the
CDL playlist so for those of you
interested in the competitive scenes
yeah getting some competitive playlists
kind of gives me some you know throw
backs to win like halo had the MLG
playlist like in matchmaking didn't have
to worry about making custom game types
or whatever yeah so that's exciting for
the competitive ones out there but yeah
a few more minutes left of our chat
while we get more people into the stream
and then we're gonna get started with
some multiplayer action we're mostly
gonna be running the rest playlist they
have a whole playlist just for us right
now
oh yeah 6v6 and of course you can't
forget the beauty of cross play I'm
gonna be playing on xbox today we're
just gonna be playing on ps4 you know it
yeah had some trouble difficulty are
some technical difficulties downloading
all
but we're here now it's quite a morning
it's all here how about you guys chatter
you downloading this at home while
you're at work and stuff are you playing
here right now downloading in the chat
we're starting the download but yeah and
I honestly have not seen any responses
to what you guys want to see in a new
Call of Duty
I feel like Roli Beauty has gone through
so many different phases over the years
where it's like straight-up gunplay it's
all about you know the classic ones then
we add the jetpack ones and ones that
have already ability yeah while running
I even forgot about that but I feel like
it's been through so many phases and now
we're kind of back on the ground with
this one a little bit more yeah do you
guys like that do you want them to you
know keep pushing it that way do you
want to see them get a little more
galactic or whatever the case is space
right you know I feel like they could
really go either way with it at this
point yeah I started thinking about like
the next Call of Duty game like maybe a
few weeks ago I was like okay this is
modern warfare is doing everything right
for me personally I love it I've been
stuck on it for a while because I just
love the grind I love the game I love
the multiplayer everything about it
really but I started thinking like well
what's gonna happen next this is such a
big game it was such a big come back to
the modern warfare series what's going
on you know what's what can possibly
happen next and I don't know I have zero
answers right they could just you know
do what they do best I feel like every
Cod is generally the same they just have
small tweaks here in there that set them
apart but you know their formula is
pretty much set in stone it's just a
matter of what they're gonna decide to
do as far as like abilities or what can
they borrow from other current FPS games
right now is that the direction they
even want to go and honestly with the
fact that they're still updating modern
warfare at the moment got this new one
coming later this year I don't feel like
they're gonna stray too far from the
past I don't think so either it's
probably gonna be a next safe bet
because they and they need to keep the
momentum like normal but there's always
a balance of like how much can we change
without the fans being mad or how much
how little can we change without the
fans being mad like you know you either
you're either cutting pastes called Duty
every
or you go away to crazy and everyone
hates you so it's a hard bounce for
everyone involved I'm sure exactly we're
here just like trying to play it and
like have no involvement it just it's
mind-blowing I don't know we are yeah we
are getting started now but cozy and the
chat says Cod needs to stick to its
roots boots on the ground
with that said is this this new mode
right here classified yeah I can't click
it it just makes funny noises so we'll
just jump into multiplayer here he is
guys ghost and if you look closely he's
holding the new assault rifle I got a
shorter barrel on it but I was able to
grind it out this morning and I unlocked
both guns the growl five five six and
the striker 45 which is the UMP they're
both really good and especially on rust
which is very small I've been playing
that all morning it's crazy
I've only unlocked a few attachments as
you see with the little dots there but
if you're ready Persia or at least if
for some reason no like see I
uninstalled my must player bag
reinstalled it which usually works oh
it's not working today now I don't know
if it's because do I have to buy the
season pass you play the next to play
this season well it's fine you can run a
few while I figure my end our okay top
chat with the chat I would say what's up
thank you guys all for being here at our
2:00 p.m. slot it ran a little late but
appreciate you having here and for those
of you here you know you might not have
been able to tune in at 11 a.m. so yeah
happy to have you too Brandon her name
is in the chat what's welcome back
so here we go jumping into rust maybe
some ground war later cuz that new map
looks dope and I love ground war even
though it kind of freaks me out a little
maybe like that but you get a lot of
points and like there's so much to do
like it's always so busy
nothing busier than rust though we're
about to go 66 on rust and this is a
playlist with Kill Confirmed
headquarters hardpoint
and team deathmatch so right now it
looks like we're about to get into a
Kill Confirmed match
check out the new guns I will use I
think I'm gonna use the growl 5 5 6
first because I've had some good luck
with that the Stryker 45 aka the UMP is
also very good close range
they're great guns so get on that when
you get home y'all or if you're home
already play seen a lot of people in
chat saying they don't really have an
interest in buying a new Cod because you
like where this and that and they're
still showing support for this one which
makes yeah it's too early to be thinking
like I mean I am so happy with this that
I'm not thinking really too much about
the next one but it's inevitable you
know Joseph yeah that new classified
mode it's gotta be BR right we don't
know you watch the trailer this morning
they showed uh they showed something
look like jumping out of the plane
[Music]
three or four I forget here we go guys
Russ is bad no rust is bad with the new
gun five the new growl five five six
look ghosts look at me woo hey
everybody's gonna be ghosts today we're
ghost him what's up ghost
wish me luck yeah I hope this all your
oh look at that
right away
maybe gonna get my pad over is how we
surrounded and just like that oh yeah
stake back
there we go posting the testing honestly
a new tide every year is
idea agree with it because you know at
one point in time a new Cod every year
was like kind of cool nowadays where we
kind of live on season passes and DLC
and you know additional content and add
it on yeah I really don't feel like it
says necessary as it once were but at
the same time new gems coming they gotta
have something ready unless they're just
planning on porting this one over for
sure the last gen that switched over was
ghosts I believe that was the the game
that came out on both consoles do you
guys play ghost I play ghosts for like a
few hours like the campaign oh [ __ ] the
campaign was pretty good but the
multiplayer was like it really felt like
kind of stale to me I don't know I
played goes for just a little bit but
now I am ghost ghost
I am paranormal AF yep and I'm getting
my ass handed to me oh my god the guy in
the corner yo you know what I'm gonna
chill take it a little easier let's have
a look around the map maybe before I get
killed you guys remember all of this
parkour no time to parkour I'm getting
my ass handed to me okay seeing Alex in
the chat says I'm seriously thinking
back to the days of Halo 2 LAN parties
with my friends spending full weekends
Rocky modern warfare and the good old
days for sure
heck good times I think we're all on
that boat there we've experienced halo
to land parties you know I didn't have
slumber Fridays I had LAN parties that
was a million percent like me growing up
I remember one time my friend's parents
like went wow there was an endless sea
of enemies coming from our cream because
I was just out of luck yeah by remember
my friend's parents went out of town we
moved all their furniture into like two
rooms and then we had like completely
empty living room like dining room and
just everyone over and everyone had you
know their monitors we just played some
Halo 2 for like 30 hours straight you'll
never forget that we do someone over
here
you were you at so many tags but yeah
thanks for the walk through memory lane
there Alex oh my god I'm on a little
streak here no no I had to reload well
you guys saw that got like a three piece
about time right
Yuri about maps like rest and you know
shipment and stuff and nuketown was like
I just wish I had an unlimited clip be
so helpful all right well I've got kind
of quiet in this corner should I drop my
care package nah
alright I think I figured out what I
needed to download to get my game to
work guys soon TM woo city oh shoot man
that was sloppy oh this is madness y'all
or how are we winning I'm doing terribly
that's how it goes on this map everyone
does terribly KD out the window you know
I'm saying or is that just me making
excuses you tell me in the chaplet I
mean I stopped caring about my KD many
years ago I used to definitely you know
after every game go check my stats make
sure like I stay but above a 2.5 now I'm
just like whatever take my life I will
respawn and be back again that's kind of
how I am and it's not it's not a good
thing like look at this I'm just getting
killed back to back cuz I'm just oh I
don't know
well that's how I played up I'm always
like a rusher for better or worse in
this map it's fun but it gets my ass
killed a lot honestly as you know each
iteration of Call of Duty came about you
had to change the way you would rush you
know rushing isn't the same in every
single time so I feel that because I
like to run and gun but you know it's
not as easy as it used to be
I also useful a hardcore allies oh yeah
one stray bullet in like the back of the
shin would kill them like food and dying
right there yeah that's true
quick in the chat asking is the battle
past any good you guys
so far I'm digging it it helped you know
push it forward and get those new guns
right away yeah so had terminal in
Afghan map this season terminal is one
of my favorite Maps
I mean you could accidentally get
spawned tried pretty hard on that one
but look I got to kill the game URI kill
he says he was getting Bob he had the
most kills on team let's go oh oh oh
what's the cop yeah let's not spill the
coffee all over this expensive equipment
we have got in here I am still
downloading my update I have about two
gigs left's but yeah join you soon right
yeah
King Omar in the chat says can't even
play right now cuz he's still dead
it's a big and I will use the this I use
the growl five five six in that last
match for better or worse you guys
checking out the new games new Gary
akimbo gameplay I got to figure out it I
think it's a perk that I have to unlock
first and I don't have it you know they
classify everything you don't have so I
don't have that perk unlocked yet I
believe that's how it works
the apart as soon as it happens though
you'll see it here akimbo they brought
that back to you can't believe it
claymores weren't really helping me
there they were okay in that match Josh
when the chat says I know they changed
around some of the perks most
importantly moving overkill did that
destroy some of our current classes or
how does that work oh you know what
leave back out of this lobbying show you
guys the additions they do yeah and we
need to show ya okay for sure cuz we did
promise we were gonna do that yeah and I
just jumped right into a game
here we go if you look at perk one of
the the tiers here you see the green
text that signifies the update so
double-time now has a half tactical
sprint recharge time so you can run
faster quicker yo D removed hacking
ability out to the spotter / okay so
things are getting shuffled around here
for the scavenger perk nothing's changes
on the item yes that is super smart
list rated slots with the overkill Berg
the kill chain did interest moving on a
perk row - recharges the time reduced by
5 seconds that was already pretty sure I
thought 30 seconds was fine but I don't
use restock that much hardline nothing
overkill traded slots with kill PO we
went over that high alert nothing's
changed for ghosts oh the snapshot
grenade immunity has been moved to the
battle hardened perk hmm so it's been
removed from here and added to another
one ok interesting balancing this is
important for me because I like to take
UAVs out of the air and like play
objectives if I'm playing like
domination or something I try to get the
points that way awesome because some of
the kill streaks like an older Call of
Duty's some of those kill streaks would
take like maximum 2 rakats right yeah
now they eat more than 2 rakats and you
need help like someone needs to shoot it
with you because yep you know you just
need more damage so yeah that's
interesting
except for UAVs we're really loving that
yeah I'm really loving that they're
putting off every detail that they've
changed that's really good preciate that
too yeah for sure
added gas resistance to battle hardened
and then the snapshot grenade immunity
they added the hack ability to spotter
which is cool spotter was uh already
good over on its own is this okay now
what do y'all think nice water
I don't you spotted very much what did I
use I used ample ah because I always
have the rocket on my back but let's go
to the battle pass itself yeah about to
be point man Brock point man Brock here
we go so I grinded up this morning we
bought the deluxe like bundle pack this
morning but I also grinded this more
so we'll start from the beginning I'm
gonna go through everything in great
detail but there's ghost he's the first
thing you get and some watches MX PE
what are these called blueprints
stickers the new guns come within the
part of the pack that you bought yeah
the first one did the where is it the
growl five five six is unlocked at level
15 in the battle pass okay so the deluxe
battle pass I believe goes up to like
level twenty something so you get this
right away if you buy the deluxe bundle
pass battle pass and the other gun the
striker 45 comes later but here's where
I'm at now more blueprints stickers you
know skins the works there is the excuse
me the striker 45 there it is unlocked
at level 31 here is that skin which one
the ghost one Oh ghosts if you're
talking about ghosts that's tier one of
the battle pass check it out but if
you're talking guns there's plenty I
mean you can go down the line as soon as
you download this yourself at home if
you'd like but there's guns there's what
I call blueprints for plenty of guns
we're at level let's see just about
level 32 and at level 31 you get the
ump45 oh sorry
striker 45 that's probably the biggest
takeaway now but if we keep going I'll
show you the rest I'll just skim through
you know stickers guns and charms
I like there's guns on guns and of
course are they called yeah these
emblems and I forget what those are
called these skins are looking pretty
dope of course you can be a baller and
press square and buy them all the way as
many tiers as you want but uh no it's
not really how we roll but here we go
here's the rest of the battle pass as
you guys can see here if you have any
specific questions shoot I think we've
got it all covered but
are there any new game modes there are
yeah back up here and they introduced on
day one they introduced three v3
gunfights I would be horrible at that
yeah me too but to have a new gunfight
map also so that I mean if you if you're
into that you want to see honestly I
really love that they they're getting
like cheeky with the playlist names I
have rusty rusty yep so there's no new
game mode within the rust playlist but
it's their gun fight is back there was a
few more I think like down the line
there will be more there's gonna be
infested ground war more gunfights tough
gunfight or tournament so it's all there
it's a hefty download that's why it's
taking you guys so long like it took us
so long this morning so let's what do
you guys say hop into some more rust
yeah yeah the new guns and then maybe
ground more the new big map probably the
reason yeah probably the reason it's
taking so long to download you know
ground war maps are massive I have
almost finished my download here for
whatever this is that I didn't have for
some reason your clothes like a little
piece of it's 0.8 percent left oh man
we're Evan
how are you want we're playing on the
ps4 we downloaded it this morning our
office has like pretty good gigabit
internet and it's for everything yeah so
we know the struggle if you guys are out
there downloading it hopefully you're
tuning in to get a feel for it it's dope
I mean I'm a big Cod fan especially for
this game specifically amount of work
completed
can I please play we definitely went for
the course at the same time it's the
only word that sums it up really well
gawrsh Robert in the chat yeah this is
not true where is it
as soon as Persia gets her Xbox
situation set up we'll play together
easier
yeah boxes giving her trouble hates me
that's you know the first thing we
should get out of the way
Dr says cod ghosts' was so underrated my
god I I agree I actually did like ghost
alright y'all I'm gonna play nearly as
much as like black ops 3 or cod4 but I
definitely enjoyed it alright come on
game just work with me here oooh
domination on this map we're toast guys
I think they're doing a PR just like
every other content creator I definitely
think they're 1,000,000% putting it in
here I mean there's classified playlists
here
I felt like got a little teaser at the
end of the trailer ah everyone's just
flashing it's all coming back I feel
like I'm playing Modern Warfare 2 all
over again no I need a smoke grenade
class for sure dang it you know what I
can edit a smoke grenade into oh yeah
shoutouts to you quality of life you
know changes like that okay
edit a class while you're I mean you
can't edit everything but you can edit
enough yeah and on the fly and that's
what's important yeah exactly I feel
like the next thing we need to add is
clearing all like little green
notifications you get when you unlock
something new and your inventory yeah
that needs to go shoot that dude was
lost so much no no dang it
alright well we got the lead with two
flags on point thank goodness
what the hell I saw UAV yes it went away
they took a from us you bastards they
hide on tape I don't know what's wrong I
feel like I've downloaded every
multiplayer pack that they've asks for
it and every time I try to play it says
you need download something oh no this
is the worst map to get this to have
this problem
oh no the chopper got hurt where the
yeah this guy is having game of his life
right now he's like yes oh my god he's
gonna he's now he's targeting me can
tell that's there we go thank goodness
he had to go hey get outta here
Oh quick so it's really one follower
that was my fave I love that map that is
so good popula Oh Oh from mono warfare -
oh yeah - dude everyone loves that
that's just oh no I was just trying to
get a y'all hey but we have VNC that's
good news I swear as I did that oh come
on I had shots on that guy maybe I
should have create our pre or new
weapons yes sweet yeah - the new weapons
unlocking there's one more on the way
this season we are playing right now
with one of them this is the striker 45
aka the UMP 45 its back it's good it's
loud check it out oh shoot I jump right
into that line of fire I'm also playing
as ghost right now so I'm we're getting
some major modern warfare 2 vibes
think this annoying see you avi can't
get it out let me get out of there right
now over gone my most favorite one
that's a sniper because I really
struggle with maps that have a lot of
greenery and stuff really you know I
just picture myself beating
knife-like beyond control at the
overgrown is just like a sniper's dream
[Music]
is it working this console hates me me
oh man I forgot a head I don't have
claymores on right now I just removed
them Oh so sometimes this is this this
ladder gets stuck right there in the
middle now it's working yeah now it's
working fortunately I feel like I never
make it up that ladder I die yeah you
get your target for sure
all right we're doing good on our that
gotten I got missed it
come on I want to take out that stupid
little Wilson mr. Wilson over here ah
[Music]
all for nothing that was awful get the
stopping rounds on this this gun is
pretty dope hey I was behind the wall
delete the whole game and redownload it
I don't have enough power of sanity left
to do something like that
yeah no way man I can try to just delete
them feels the multiplayer pack again
Andrey downloaded it which I already did
before this but you know what else do I
have this game is huge already and this
doubt this update was ridiculous lists I
have seen the chat for president oh crap
and hope for the best
lose the beat oh no shoot that guy's
dead already
wonderful wonder what was that guy using
oh okay it's a spec ops I will look I
did download a second spec ops pack that
I asked me that said I didn't have so I
did download that one already just now
Oh
new battle past tears yeah we're getting
some hay they put me on a though let's
see let's go I'm sick of that guy in the
red he's out getting me dude there was
three come on that was I mean I'm
already not a wonderful player as it is
like help me out here Activision help me
out this counter UAV is hitting I think
I can't see [ __ ] I'm dead watch oh he
was giving up there gadzooks alright
this has got to go that UAV I that
counter UAV I hate those yeah I guess I
rely on the UAV a lot more than five
stance sitting ducks out here
sad life yeah it was oh my goodness what
does it progress I think that eventually
right uh like if you didn't level up to
155 it won't save it'll just I think it
like starts over
actually I forget how it goes I should
play a little more a little safer I
think I'm going to crazy the VTOL it's
the worst kill shake in the game is it
interesting until yeah those are like
they take three rockets so they're not
the strongest but oh my gosh I'm sorry
guys
but they're annoying they're they're bit
they hit pretty hard I don't know I've
had bad experience being on the other
end of one yeah I guess if you have perk
to not be targeted then yeah bad things
bad thing I hate that yeah that guy
again oh that time I just missed my
shots I knew it and he changed one thing
there yeah I'm already going nuts here
with the sensitivity I just stink at
this game you know oh shoot that was a
badge bond but I don't know how I lived
man okay alright I need to re-evaluate
and my rust decisions would you say
you're a little
I have rust issues remember that guy
he's got to go
okay and we camp out a little bit
because I've been getting my ass handed
to me lungs were in the lead oh my gosh
I don't know about the beetle water
they were like were seven you know
underpowered overpowered Travis this is
it it's Russ baby look at that awful
look how many deaths
oh well fortunately it passed but I did
shitty that round you want to try Persia
let me back out I can change the
sensitivity in the tactical mode and we
can switch chairs if you want yeah yeah
William Nunez is screaming is there
battle royale you know what there is a
classified mode Persia would you press
are you a you're in a lobby in your mind
if you go to the main menu after you've
downloaded season 2 there's like you
know multiplayer co-op campaign and
there's a there's like a new one that
says classified so mmm we're all
thinking we're all thinking battle
royale nothing confirmed by activision
or Infinity Ward but it's definitely
hinted maybe later this season it's
looking good
and at the end of the chain oh yeah good
I got the new guns there's a I have a
class for both if you want it's like
class yeah those two yeah I'm like if I
have done this all the whole game I'm
not doing that
1 million percent the last few times
running into this issue I was able to
just uninstall the monster player pack
and reinstall it but like that works
anymore
so I'm just gonna have to wait for a day
where I can do all that jazz oh boy
Chris heart says it's definitely battle
royale and it has to be I mean the we've
it's been a while John welcome to the
channel welcome to the stream stop
Travis is asking did they add new trials
to the battle fest I got a look I
actually haven't
I don't really mess with the trials that
much but yeah we'll look after this
match let's check out yep not in the
chat is excited about rust it looks
better than ever guys I mean it there
was nothing like there wasn't too much
to this map but it's just so good to see
it again you know
now you can 1v1 people on rust yeah
that's another thing I've been playing a
headquarters on this playlist all
morning and it's great because people
forget how to play headquarters yeah and
you can win pretty easily tip kill this
Frank says yo brother please play 3d
three snipers one time oh we love the
2v2 3v3 gunfight but snipers were both
like you might not want to see that but
it's part of the new season no magic 360
no-scope yeah you're gonna see a lot of
us [ __ ] our pants solo defending the
HQ hold it down hold it down no no no
there you go he's got this he's got this
we're in the lead with 39 oh they're
taking it shoot
down he stayed alive he did onion soup
says but do we need and then add the
yummy I'm gonna say that wrong forgive
me he says we definitely need to be our
[Music]
apex apex came back really strong this
is rust
this is classic rust I mean it's it's
sort of a nightmare but it's thrilling
no Frank is like if there's regular 3v3
I'm down to watch that - it was it was
called like 3v3 snipers only so I don't
know maybe
oh man everyone's just getting dropped
right now I should check that crown area
because I think he was there actually
the whole time
that's all right the other team is going
around shooting us and they're not
jumping on the headquarters it's open
now we just had yeah there you go
accidentally all right what are your
guys's memories in the chat with Ross
did you guys play warfare 2 or am I too
old oh is that like your first Call of
Duty game
I thought that two naps 77 in the chat
says the novelty of ghosts will wear
thin when everyone is picking him I kind
of thought that too like sheriff there's
only there's one and only ghost right
but everyone's ghost now it's kind of
funny but day one I'm still with it oh
oh I got with no sleeves
I don't know first I didn't see up I
didn't see a body the dude keeps
disappearing yeah I do with like a fly
oh nasty fall they go okay HQ is not
ready yet at a yummy and the chat says
oh shipment was the worst it's bad name
I don't know if you know [ __ ] me either
lover you hate it I like that oh em
black ops 2 call the beauty mobile also
oh really
frank says headquarters on shipment was
hella dope it's very chaotic it's kind
of like this so I mean if you're into
that for sure I was like I'm not gonna
chase you boat lived though by the way
if you're just tuning in this is the new
gun this is the growl five five six
assault rifle
we got a shorter barrel on it it does
more damage but at a shorter range
what I literally shot him in the face
you got stopping power rounds if you
want to use them don't let him get on
that Oh what the the headquarters that's
all right right now someone's there whoo
hi jack that's what it's called the boat
the the cruise liner and Travis in the
chat thank you for my he says it's an
amazing map really it is like one of my
tops hey you like to work through people
there there's a lot of going on over
there just they're bombing this corner
cat let me know where you guys are at
with your downloads cuz this was a
massive download or you guys halfway
there did you download it and then like
go to work
share share with us try the
there you go oh there you go nice first
kill like right away
nine hours left unruly I hope you hope
you're lying bro nine hours oh no I mean
it is a massive update people were
saying like some people were saying for
hours I guess it just depends this
morning
it was like jumping up back and forth
yeah randomly go down a half hour and
they won't jump up to an hour
quick quick in the chest says I got 12
minutes left I'm high woo
hopefully they hope to see you out here
and the battlefield quick no quick what
are you gonna play are you gonna play
some ground war jump right into rust let
me know five minutes left
Iceman is that way Iceman yeah sorry the
screen all black ops 2 maps are bangers
I mean it was a great game probably
because of all the good maps or at least
a multiplayer I feel like three
sensitivity and this game is slower than
the average three sensitivity for some
reason you can change it if you want
that guy or you have the knock ego says
I have 30 minutes left
oh yeah JK I'm not gonna there's always
someone up there whenever I try go up
there they smoke me J cabe behave please
we don't want to we don't want to put
you on timeout
[Music]
there's always one guy yeah oh yeah oh
don't know if I'm liking this I should
be more than I like him than me with
salt oh oh oh grateful
so far come on come on Jack I just
killed me literally and the fact that
he's been I'm the worst
I'm up here
oh are they all dead just a beige cue
there we go oh nice duck no Jim in the
chat says he's happy that they're
teasing Battle Royale we got a fan all
right I don't like the news well it's
not that I don't think it's good not
very good with submachine guns got this
you know what that was that was some guy
with no chill there's no time to chill
here
oh my glory can you get out the way
anyone remember the map is state says
Travis Oh the state is good although
remember in the story after you do the
estate mission you go and you meet a
shepherd and he takes out ghosts it's
one of the worst moments in caught
history please back so yeah yeah like
legit those the first time I think this
whole game nice
oh you guys remember dome that was
another crazy map yeah a little spawn
trap you but pretty good yeah so was
this one but like there's so much so
many memories with it and it's chaos
it's like one of those small maps like
dome shipment or nuketown that everyone
just loves you know well love it or hate
I think they're really scary to quiet
SLV says sit down wolf kid you gotta
cook Baker yes this is rust from modern
warfare 2 and this morning season 2 of
modern warfare launched and Russ was
Russ is returning Russ is here
I think of Rockets as your backup but if
you wanted if you want to go that route
oh they're there they're not responding
because that's that's the rule of HQ
after a certain time that responds are
not allowed Robbie says I'm happy Russ
is back I can once again meme it to my
friends someone new 1v1 me heck yeah
what oh that's wolf Smith all this is
Cody Rodriguez asks if battle royale
season is this season or next they're
kind of teasing it for this season
nothing's confirmed I'm thinking halfway
through this season we might see it
always have whatever is on that you know
kill streaks can't see you Oh ghost yeah
yeah off the radar stuff I normally did
- yes I can have some freedom to run
around you know what did you guys think
of favela ooh you missed our chat about
we all love favela here it's just
freaking out about it
Hey look you got the you got the kills
but he did not play the objective one
time that's the class people are just
used to playing like TDM and they don't
they don't play headquarters so they
just keep going for the kills
levelling up the battle pass me back out
of here see what we unlocked there
there's no green dots for things you
unlocked I think it's a bug but like
this is the gun we used and like we
unlock some things but it's not letting
us know of it I don't really mess with
those rest man map is classic classic
okay what should we check out next
Persia I know the town wanted to see
some of this 3 V 3 sniping action fair
warning it's not gonna be great it's
here yeah but we can put it for you chat
we have to at least see what's up right
yes I wouldn't go home and I remember
raid raid was cool I always like going
into the garage being like ooh car I
remember the name raid I can't think of
it though it had like a little circular
courtyard and there was a little house
and then there was another like
rectangular courtyard was like some
water in the middle which you can go
back around like the pool
was it him well is that a black ops man
um I don't remember I don't remember
what's wrong was sexually alright y'all
gunfight and uh in the cargo map this
one was introduced last season but it's
still it's still a fun small map why so
epic asks who's gonna buy the paddle
bass for the battle pass for me seem oh
man they gave me this gun to the dragon
off geez look at that 80s oh there's not
a sniper guys I'm a shitty submachine
gun in guy so wish me luck feel free to
laugh at me black ops 2 boomer
that's what game is it was raid ok yeah
I know what you're talking about now I
was peeking my head around like an idiot
so I deserve that yep see ya hate that
guy well I'm gonna make excuses all day
because I don't like this night but uh
this is what you got y'all asked for
that is not a visible corner damn they
took out my man so fast I know it's like
got caught peeking the crazy thing about
playing sniper specific Maps like I was
like you just got a guess right pick the
right corner that was that was me
freaking out and like responding poorly
there's only one guy left so you could
just run around and be bait and then
hope he misses serpentine patterns
Ritchie
alright times almost up though what
happens oh no you K you died over there
now it's up to you
the flag nope
oh you hit him you hit him that was
sloppy but we got the job done yeah I
shot his gun I coulda shot his finger
goes sorry goes alright well it's tied 1
V 1 or 1 to 1 right now
wish me luck I'm trying to slide oh you
have tactical oh yeah no biggie
watch he's gonna come right through here
come on [ __ ] same this up a little so
you can hear footsteps
oh I rely on footsteps heavily when I'm
playing I can appreciate the tactical
layout it's classic I just I never got
into it I'm just a drop shotting scrub
that's all
oh no they took out one of us is ghost
voiced by og no it's not oh no it's just
me versus two I'm toast
oh the help of the regenerate I am
capital F oh no yes sorry Martin yeah
the og actor voice actor is not back but
his replacement sounds really good
goodness for goodness sake
oh come on I hit him once and he hit me
once
MLG no yeah Florida this is what you
were asking for right I know I forget if
those I'm it's not a sniper I'm barely
I'm like a passable regular like some
machine gunner seen some terminal lows
in the chat safety and terminals my map
it's definitely oh we jump for it
oh okay that was just good timing that
guy took out two guys in like five
seconds okay well we have at least the
mk2 carbine I cannot I shouldn't go up
there ever again that's like popular
area to go to okay they're both up there
please see them all right to v1 come on
team we can are you guys snipers let me
know in the chat if you guys your
preferred right what's the what's the
yeah yeah cuz that that you've told me
that my whole life and it's never worked
so let's try something else no equipment
no if I go up there I'll set you up
again okay Express was a good Maps it's
faith boertie for I feel like with
snipers so you have to be really really
good to be good with snipers so
sometimes I guess brush down and work
for the best that's I mean I'm that was
sloppy but it worked I guess freaking
out it should be a bra moment me dying
bro yeah okay I see so much
search-and-destroy and terminal was
definitely one of my favorites for
search specifically because you know he
was posted up I don't know why I took
that guy on your health doesn't
regenerate and I keep forgetting fate
asks how was BRTS well in the trailer
this morning I'm tired
the opening cinematic of season 2 which
was in the game they show people jumping
out of a plane like just for a second in
the last and then also in the main menu
of this game where it says multiplayer
co-op SpecOps there's a fifth option
that says classified so there's gonna be
a new game mode and they're teasing it
hard I'll show you after this match
after I die here nice to zoo let's go
they're both there
they're both come on come back come back
he's gonna come around I hate this gun I
hate this gun I hate this knife my
teammate he had the right idea he was
going for it at least and the gas at the
end Oh Florida bringing up the season 2
trailer again there was gas like they
had to leave the building because gas
was filling the room in the trailer
alright do you want to try this mode or
like are we satisfied ok I'll suffer
with you let me fix this here three four
three
yeah let's do four cow we are back
yes snippety snipe these fools Kaleb
thank you for the ass darkness yeah drop
the apps guys we need more f's
at least it wasn't a full shutout I
didn't really contribute to that because
I'm not a good sniper but sniping was
you only get so many bullets in a clip
especially I hate that oh no it didn't I
just say I'm horrible I'm like Foresti
Maps oh you can back out if you want but
he'll this map yeah
three three snipers I just feel like I
never look in the right spot on the
first go and then someone's like in
another spot and they see me that's how
yeah I feel like everyone always gets
the best of me in a sniper situation
I'll thank you Caleb after the clutch
y'all are too sweet you know that chats
you know commenting on my sensitivity
there used to be a day where I played on
one sensitivity alright I have levelled
up four times that and I'm trying to
find I went crazy during modern warfare
3 I think I maxed out at 10 and then use
like those advanced thumb sticks that
were a little taller for more
sensitivity I was going of course they
give you the greatest sniper in this
game Bailey says Russell's chaos he
added you were here Bailey I think when
we were playing rust is chaos no matter
what no matter how good of a player you
are you can be better at people than
rust baby
ouch I know they shouldn't like
animation like seeing ghosts die still
hurts my feelings
they shouldn't animate it they should
not have make that like death animation
you just stand you got this you got this
one more die Oh
where I wish I thought my team went down
I was like no I don't look at that
no scoop I never scope you guys jump
shot in Call of Duty let me know I don't
and I I can't feeling you should execute
you got what do you guys think of
bringing back Pripyat has a spec ops
mission hmm wait is that top of my head
let's I'm gonna double-check the stats
to see to confirm on day one there is
rust the superstore the ground of the
ground war map
I look I don't look at you guys
yeah rest is in the TV to bench gunfight
see if we can get that going
that'd be a perfect I think that's
coming later was that a part of it it
does say and more so like it's may or
may not be how Bailey I read that in
that voice 50,000 people used to live
here now it's a ghost town who's a
captain prices commander forgot his name
[Music]
Oh Bailey yeah the propia that's the
that's the map you're talking about with
the ferris wheel am I getting closer
right
oh man oh man Leonard in the chat was
like what he knew McMillan Thank You
Caleb oh if you guys how's it going with
your downloads checking in is it done
yet 51 I want opinion so bad no pinging
all right you're doing much better than
I am
much better part of the stream no Caleb
says eight hours left no oh yeah you you
winning as like some date right there
right and then he took it cleaned up
look at this right is that guy gave up
on me he was like whatever I'm going
over here baby I'm like if I just keep
moving enough I might you know outlive
it you did it
Florida says I'm at 57% yes let's go are
you guys probably gonna play all night
huh as soon as it's done downloading
that day I was like I said like it's so
hard to watch like what it's already
stressful enough to play well you're
watching like someone like that's
probably how you guys all feeling
digging the test says I'm just gonna be
playing rush 66 all day I had to calm
down right there nice like let me not
just panic fire you guys know how it is
if you like that you just see them there
you just start mashing you're like
that's me I'm terrible with the sniper
in general Oh both played there that was
for you guys yeah
shout-out to those who can't who can't
play right now and are still downloading
we're here for you
indeed I can't even play on console
that's okay let's try out the new ground
war map see what's up
we haven't done this in a while guys let
me back up and show you what I'm talking
about see this fifth mode right here
classified doesn't work we're thinking
is Br
we're pretty sure that's the guess yeah
so until then let's go to back to
multiplayer play some grand war
hopefully it puts us right into the new
map because the old maps are good but
we're here to show off the new goodness
the new happiness didn't work I guess
that means I'm gonna have to uninstall
the entire game and reinstall the same
time for that right now so I'm just
gonna kindly take this controller
put it over here and hold that shape
alright it's being held there we go
uh-huh dig in the chest says maybe
that's zombies yes we're right there
teasing but they did officially already
it was like yeah infected infected
ground Warren it's coming it's happening
so why would it be classified oh man I
think yeah me said good one for sure way
thank you yes alright I backed out of
that Lobby because it was the point of
her dance kit wasn't the new map we want
the new map yes give us the new new what
are you doing good good how big was the
update Oh big ps4 big 50 gigs pc big 68
years yeah and then I think the Xbox one
was like 660 also 16 like yeah oh yeah
that's why our stream no gosh darn it
although I do like that Palace map how
much is season 2 uh if you want a full
go full ball over 20 bucks and I think
like 10 for
yeah I think 10 for the regular starter
pack is the tournament 3v3 or 2v2 I
don't know I'm sure we haven't clicked
on that yet I don't know I see you mean
the gunfight oh nice the gunfight
tournament I think it's to be to think
think don't quote me
although the 3v3 even though the sniper
is felt pretty fun not gonna lie mmm
cross-play says getting SSD it's a
faster download yeah if you have a ps4
there's quick quick way to just take out
your old hard disk drive and replace it
with an SSD it's not it's not cheap
though but that would speed things up a
little bit here we go okay do I have
what class should I use let's use the
new assault rifle although I'm gonna
edit it because I want longer range I'm
gonna remove target is acquired
I started using random like Call of Duty
phrases IRL way more often than I should
or like in other games
all right y'all me mute the chat here
and here is the new looking spacious on
this side this is looking also like that
airplane I think it might be the same
you know airplane graveyard from Modern
Warfare 2 which is like the last second
to last mission you play chat if you
remember or if you can confirm let me
know looking good though junior and says
season two is pretty lit and think he
would know
Charlie what
sorry I thought I saw you ID I heard
something oh yeah was behind me now I'm
not even happy with that
I'm pretty bad at camping
[Music]
you need some sort of restraints and
this to an extent
going around oh he left it jerk you left
one of those things I'm hiding out yo
this is too crazy
we're making our way sloppy we're making
our way over here to their side oh he is
contested oh that means they're gonna
take me from us yeah they said that
that's probably gonna lay right on
see what did I tell you the unrest Karen
said I've never played ground war is it
close to battle kill for big loads yes
yes it is the closest thing you can get
to that please sure yeah
would be like someone through
battlefields heads in the office they
really like what happened
we had a B and C and now it's like just
II watch out man
no no no forehead right up off of Christ
there's like four people in that hangar
and the guy shoots you known for a
because no one's here
Oh
is that the position come on I'm just
trying to go for a that dude was around
the astronomy yeah he's always so many
people you don't know all the time it's
they've already been killed or if
they're still you know running around
it's chaos
don't break come on let's all go for a
friends oh no already good to know I'm
gonna hang out here until this is over
nope watch out man I just yet but they
did it well I'm gonna try to go for oh
they're going for be good good good
that's how you win this round watch at a
squatch at you know see on the left of
my screen there's four of us
you have little you have chat between
those four and I haven't mute it just so
you know so we can for today good they
got beat let's go for see we've got
three points
oh shoot okay they're taking they're
slowly taking B so that means one like
one or two guys I still want to clear
that yeah I don't want that smoked enemy
over Oh
all the um yeah might as well use my
rocket look bro tena can I get a sec oh
look at that
yes no I almost went for the duck one of
you one here on this big mean maybe I'm
a community Friday
by the way this is just a reminder this
is the new assault rifle we got we're
about to catch up with our points but
I'm gonna hide over here and use my see
you later Brandon thanks for tuning in
well you have a good rest of your day as
well appreciate you man
come back and see us tomorrow my care
packages no time like the present
one I kind of like that this version
will have the little white X over if
they're like under it's very helpful
Dale said what's new with season two so
much to new guns ghost is back as an
operator this ground war map were
playing
rust is back
Oh
[Music]
good
a tree stump what's happened here
friendly I love that I get points for
that I'm so stupid
I just hate those things what the hell
did I do
keep it off the radar cold-blooded and
ghost and I'm ghost baby
can't see me I can't tell who's shot
driving well I know that one always got
me about this mode I'm like is that fun
all the way in the back of the map I
like that one person yep to walk by I've
tried it and that's what happens to me
I'll be there for a hot minute maybe one
person I try to go post up somewhere
more active and be a man I just it's all
me just a split second look at this
we're about to lose well at least you
guys get to see the map going for a
again
enemy what they cut off that was sloppy
not sure our lungs this game yeah oh no
contested oh where the hell he's behind
us
I think someone else took him out see
we're about to lose to death oh okay
good we got alpha yeah I think we need a
little bit more than all the right now
yeah well you know Jesus
already going down okay that was just me
giving like a middle finger as it's
going down
so loud smash me to hearing if I don't
see you enemy movement
one guy's far away oh it's right there
I saw three yeah this guy can you step
outside of that place agree they're
taking go
Oh
[Music]
Oh gopher be dead end all right finally
you gotta feel like this is hotter than
ever
he was waiting for you Jesse Ryder
alright yes this is what I'm talking
about let's go ahead get out of here oh
no it was a risk yeah try again oh this
is about to blow up No
I'm never driving that
we're dead alright I'm gonna try to go
for II wasn't revenge killed
whose ghost contestant oh no shoot I'm
paranoid been exposed
come on don't sneak up on me I'm
freaking out I'll bring it out come on
I'm mighty by myself this is taking
forever come on so I'm gonna get
executed from behind watch like oh my
god I'm out of here at this I don't care
he was contested already what
[Music]
Oh 40 oh yeah how we're losing now I
can't even believe looking like a
Reynolds Wrap hopefully at the nuke yeah
you go in the hall again
[Music]
place your bets what is it called
better than UAB we needed the new
all right they were pissing off at ease
other inside little X's I know I thought
I could make it through the window
what a wish
[Music]
like that yeah well we got a B C and O
we don't have the little Cruiser
I don't know how about targeting this
thing where
oh yeah we're coming back you need that
last point real bad though yeah dude
come on let me go back up - thanks
Virgil take this moment
you guys well that route okay enjoy
hanging out with us today because we
enjoy hanging out and see you guys every
weekday usually at 11 a.m. Pacific Oh
oops not yet you wait hold up usually at
11 a.m. Pacific time today was at 2 p.m.
because obviously we wanted to be able
to download the update and it took a
little longer then expected but it's all
good
tomorrow we're gonna be playing some
apex Legends duo's mode will be live to
party there Valentine's Day event so
make sure yeah until then enjoy yourself
some Cod good luck with all of your
downloads out there and thanks so much
for joining us hope you guys come back
we'll see you next time